okay yeah all right oh yeah we're ready
cherish fresh from a very hot Phoenix
it's did you notice that when we got
there we got to our Airbnb we saw a dead
dove and he died from he probably none
of us picked it up
we just left we can try to me it's ours
well I was gonna pick him up with a give
him a proper burial on a plastic bag and
put him in the trash no I said we just
left him there
no one even touch what we're all scared
of it but eyes are though yeah but I'll
split but I up well I thought about oh
maybe those run Roadrunners them there's
a bunch of road runners they don't eat
their own bird they'd only bait insects
but like like some could eat it it was
kind of an ominous thing add of the
symbol of peace play dead he was dirty
though
dirty dove three six three sticks three
six three then Murray three black men
and three white men we we represent to
182 white men what are they to blacks
yeah that's I met but I was thinking on
Justin Justin too though oh yeah Justin
was there [ __ ] yeah you're right Justin
there they all did so great how about
that show the last show it was just in
the house Justin's last name
it was Moloch how great is that
[ __ ] hey what's your pal that's a
great shot right there yeah yeah go go
up to the one of Chappelle do in the
back flip the picture of my dad right
obscene top right that's the greatest
picture in comedy sir I would imagine so
comments okay look at Malik's face I
told Troy cuz he did the first show I
went dude next time he does that make
sure you send me a picture of him with
fully upside down it's gonna be the post
of the week man you gotta get it it's so
good desert honey savages desert honey
savages Stevie blue eyes some of the
best shows we've I would say some best
shows I've ever had 100 percent that
early Thursday is a little tough I just
want to do that all the time well the
early shirt well let me just say this
Meir if you saw me early Thursday and
I'm gonna say it out loud
I've been doing comedy for a long time
some people would say I do pretty well
at comedy some people would say the best
one of the best some but I've heard that
well maybe some people would say I make
you laugh hard for a long time right
I haven't had set that bad in 20 years
even Kobe has an off night I'm telling
you dude yeah I came off but you know I
went but if I knew something I knew
something was up because Malik starts
the show he might be the best opener our
he's a killer
cousin he's a killer but its energy so
good I subscribed aunt and he comes back
and I go how is it for early Thursday
you know he hasn't been doing it that
long
no and I didn't want to tell him hey
Thursday's are usually tough yeah even
though he's been doing but sure you know
so it switched out of quarantine
Thursday's me a little tough oh yeah so
he gets off stage and I go how are they
I could tell you yours they're a little
tight but you know they come around and
then then Chappelle goes out then
Chappelle comes back and goes man how
are they is it's fun out there I'm like
fun that's a weird thing I say if I go
out I'm like oh I eat dick well I can
tell you came out and I go how are they
they can you go they're there they're
you know they're there they're there
they're out there that was a weird
answer I come out like here goes
everybody huh huh so early it was the
strangest thing and then we were all a
little down like well and then late
Thursday was crunk of [ __ ] a cry cat
Kroenke [ __ ] and how about Saturday
night Late Show
how about Saturday for shift work Rock
Show how about Saturday Wharf 7 on John
killers kill us
it's a great show with all of us - it
was so I want to do that all the time
Stevie and there's my dick so first of
all we're all swimming and Brian's hey
lingering around just flinging around
wouldn't get in the water we're not
stupid hat and finally I'm saying what
everyone's thinking I oh dude get your
old dick and balls out of our face I
wore hammer and I said instead my stick
that's my sensei get your since then a
lot of sin and that old honey pouch yep
out of my face dude yeah that's and I
said you want stay there let me get a
picture
and I posted that I am disgusted by my
body I'm looking at my torso I'm looking
at my chest my white skin people have
that big a heavy sack people think you
stuffed your boxes I unfortunately I did
he does it every town has a peak I laugh
when we're naked like like if we're
changing some I just laugh at your body
you said look Chinese are really like
fat droopy dick it's like I got a weird
sorry I can't okay
you came in you just saw my dick all cuz
it was hot and it was just hanging like
it just don't care like a big old lazy
son of a [ __ ] Holly I can sack of meat
in this happy doesn't move much he's
just a big old dick and you can't you
can't laughing so are you got you got
had hey Jake came in and start laughing
you guys just laughing at my big holes
didn't you dick laughing huh yeah I do
pretty well on that bar but I find that
even sure to be so discussed that bars
put damn no girl it was great it was
great
boy oh boy God we had a good time we had
such it's the perfect with Stevie Malik
J Chappell Justin Lee you call him Malik
Modi girl name is Moloch Moloch but it's
okay cuz you can call him Malik because
that would be like homo any black man
named Moloch is Malik but Moloch his dad
was like now your name is Malik so tough
I know so Moloch but it's just the
perfect combination now he likes it's
like the perfect Lego piece and we even
had a wrestling match to me hold on you
go to Stevie if you go to Stevie's pick
him up that barns all guys swim party
yeah bro
by the way that looks so incredibly it's
so so aggressively gay how about the
video how about Moloch the best hype man
of all time this was shot you were
dancing like that guy in that video it
was so funny no but people I realize
what that video is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the manager walked in when we were
wrestling everybody tried to last oh
hello Michael asked before hon Oh was it
fry it's Friday night or Saturday night
Friday night Friday night Friday night
wrestling mallet goes oh dude Friday
night is Friday wrestling night yeah
what is yeah we wrestle on Fridays in
the green room he goes we did that in
Houston I go all right man
i I want nothing doing so I'm sipping my
whiskey relaxing go to Stevie blue eyes
post he's opposed to the vision boxing
is her life soon I can't live down the
fact that you do with that [ __ ] to him
as a as a wrestler he doesn't know what
to do it on his uh story I put on my
story too
oh you did yeah I just hope people don't
think that gotta sit out here now
Brendan here that's the seat belt Oh God
God look at what they don't show is
Chappelle's tapping himself I was so
worried that you're gonna hurt
somebody's neck cuz you just you know
know who did Stevie did go to him
playing the [ __ ] guitars in around it
man I asked him and why is he one of
rabbits
[Music]
[Laughter]
what is new her theory self-taught
alright so when we're driving back on
Saturday night I go and I go it god I'd
love to learn how to play the guitar and
Stevie goes dude I'm I couldn't I can't
tell you chords like I don't know like I
can't teach any of that and then she
fell just me neither man we built I just
like learned when I was a kid is that we
couldn't teach him like [ __ ] thanks guys
I'm Jill I always think back to it I got
so I was signed up to play the piano
take be honest ins at 13 years old and
it was a schedule thing I just said no
and I should have done it but you had to
have them you gotta want to do it or you
don't
dude how much fun look at just look at
those posts how much [ __ ] fun do we
have buggy the one with Chappelle's
singing it's the best where I didn't see
that rapping you were onstage there Wow
snow it's so goes between the loves
first and so I got a good voice
[Applause]
yes let's go he's stupid he's so fun -
ball so much fun I want to do that every
[ __ ] weekend I would die if we did
every week I'm recouping a little bit
cuz I went to bed
see daddy gets all wired up then I went
to bed it's for yeah I mean I could
sleep I was back up at 8:00 I know what
you're thinking
you only got sleep no I got sleep I
could tell myself in Laos so [ __ ]
loud and you you wake up at 7:00 no
matter what no matter what because the
kiddos I'm up so if I get about three
for me and three hours sleep I was so
tired
plus you know that that angel heart with
angel Envy angels and angels Envy how
delicious outstanding Berman we drink
once daily for bottle yeah it's a
kentucky burp
little hungover i'll and and got an IV
right away you did right away that when
we have a hard weekend like that I get
to I'd really maybe I should do that too
IV bags and vitamins really yeah who
does that for you I need to do that
there's like connection the lady you do
that that na ad stuff no no nope just
buy replenish nutrients and fluids oh
wow cuz yeah I think we're not drinking
the fluid no nodding we're drinking when
I try to drink a lot of water yeah but
the IV just you'll feel insulin but like
I feel better today my I'm lucky because
I'm able to sleep a lot I just sleep see
I can't can't sleep I go I go I stay
deep if I'm seven and a half eight hours
I'm going home
how about when we first got in the car
to go wherever we're gonna go to the
workout place and the thermometer read
114 or the [ __ ] yeah yeah how they did
where we gonna do the dry heat III I
secretly went and looked for
rattlesnakes in the little area of saw
some snake skin Oh huh snakes
I saw road runners for the first time
yeah it's just think kids they don't
look like Road Runner that gets away
from Wiley coyote right there pretty
small yeah they don't have big legs and
they're not friendly no I kind of like
like right up I like Scottsdale
Scottsdale is great yeah didn't you [ __ ]
back Ovid did they don't give a [ __ ]
about covin if Bryant count was a bird I
go under the knife tomorrow how'd it go
get swab Oh daddy's getting uncover it's
done tomorrow daddy gets his lids done
we should document 6:30 a.m. oh now I
know too early why Sara Lee well that's
how they do it in Beverly Hills don't
they keep it poppin
well then Papa goes in at 6:30 I'll pry
the surgeon apply get there at at Jason
dr. Jason diamond he'll do it you know
probably eight does he work on the canoe
so funny I looked at my go
no no cocaine no blow I know though no
whiskey like the night before if you
don't mind cuz you're gonna he goes I'll
get it met by 4:00 I promise yeah I got
a bit before I am don't worry about and
now is there any chance that they could
have a hiccup and you look like a sniper
for the rest of your life I said to him
I said now listen I can't have you
[ __ ] this up he goes there's not a
chance
I go yeah but I read on the like was I
was so what about crew pilots you guys
oh you've been on YouTube yeah well
don't do that don't YouTube your
operation what exactly are they doing
papa they're gonna take they make an
incision to your intro of the top acre
they take this well you can take the
nuts off the top yeah take those nuts
and then they're gonna go oh they're
gonna go lower problems they're gonna go
lower and they're gonna take a little
here off here apparently he said I would
do it you getting bottom surgery and
then they shoot a little fat in the
eyelids from from my little tummy I
guess they're taking you do they get the
fat out they do a lipo
suction and I guess they sniff getting
like getting lipo
well tiny bit my eyes look I don't like
any of it I don't have a tummy bro of a
tummy goddamnit doing are you going
under for this you're saying I gotta go
on there oh I don't like that that's why
you can't drink I can't believe you have
to go under I want you to take some skin
off your dip I could have them why don't
you have them cinch up your nuts
cinch my bounty you guys knew ya got
some issues um damn you have to go under
there's nothing scarier yeah so scary
time before honey West mom died yeah get
elective surgery well I did it I did it
for a colonoscopy they stick a camera up
your [ __ ] and then I did it for my
double hernia right like I don't know
how long ago yeah one other so scary but
when you believe you have to go under to
do that though um do you know if my
stomach was never the same after a
double hernia surgery my III was like I
had that pouch like it bloats out a
little bit yeah that's what I have from
[ __ ] from my surgery how many sir how
many times you've been under just what
your nose twice for Oken nose and broken
in broken nose broken head it's so it's
so when they pack you in they unpack you
so scary
but I'm just saying when you're going in
there and like I count the ten it's like
cold you're basing day he's cold and
takes all it's like your dicks the
smallest it's never gonna be smile cuz
you're about to go under the knife it's
cold and it goes retreat I know and by
the way I think about that I think about
the nurses looking at my my title and my
tiny song yep but luckily this is my
eyes so they shouldn't be looking at my
dick
although gonna be naked all the yummy
yeah my son just water you gotta talk to
him about they're in there just do the
thing what's that just like suck all the
fat right well no not that there's that
much but you might as well fear in there
yeah
I don't you get my licking dumb I could
use a little lipo Oh careful you go down
this this road
I mean now I see [ __ ] now I I had I
sired a doctor hit me up and shows me
what they can do with people before and
after and it will blow your mind I could
come here looking like a giant Meyer
okay they do they can do anything with
no workout could eat one of the [ __ ] I
want
and Jason Diamond is recognized by the
other people in the field as the most
renowned facial surgeon he doesn't just
do plastics for bodies you got you go
ahead and take going down to TJ there's
a guy down there that a lot of celebs go
to you stay there at you there a week
recovery times about seven days wanna
and they'll take your you're stupid from
Peabody and turn you into [ __ ]
miserable yeah one yeah one cuz our boys
girl did her ass her brazilian butt-lift
in Miami yeah me Miami yeah and then she
got it done he paid for it that's a
major hombre but he paid for it she
looks ridiculous wit see yeah yeah
Savage she only does anal
congratulations she you have to massage
her but I can't you have to get massages
for like six weeks it's crazy
okay I'll do it I know me and Alton
would be the massager let me help you I
was the fat into that and he paid for it
yeah but pretty soon you're gonna be
able to use stem cells and grow your own
tissue where you need it that's gonna be
awesome you're gonna be able to grow
Sciences science in get going so much
every dude if you want to be shred it's
gonna be able to be shred I'm Tony can
do this procedure now and get shredded
and the fat never they burn it so fat
can't grow there's thing what do you
mean they sent me a whole pamphlet on
like I'm just not that what do you mean
just not at that kind of so you can get
you can get shredded
I'll some I don't want out the thing
I'll send you the stuff they sent me
like Jesus Christ it's nuts
what the [ __ ] nuts I would imagine you
could also take one stroll etc and just
get shredded but but you have to be on
one strong do like eat clean to get read
this they burn it and can't grow back
there and they can actually sculpt the
ABS [ __ ] and no and they have over a
hundred people a show before and after
you like holy [ __ ] it's so tempting but
it'd be so obvious what is it called
well here's my i yeah well the problem
is is like I'm not so superficial I'd do
it and also can you imagine if I died
that way and then tiger embossed and I
couch your dad you know a comic yeah I
know his body this was a good
he was tummy always bothered he left you
guys to become more shrim Anna T was
more important so carry that with you
the rest of your life and if you need me
I'm gonna be busy but I'll be around my
phone called probably pretty busy pretty
busy cuz you don't know what happened in
Kanye West's mom so she wanted
everything done faced stomach lipo she
was like titties ass she wanted
everything done at once and she went to
several doctors and any I'm sure you
went to diamond all of them went nope
too many you're new to the knife too
long there's so many complications well
finally she found one know some guy went
I'll do it honey West mom I'll do it
against all protocol did it when she
passed away she's down for too long
license he did oh he did dumb but still
he doesn't matter can't bring the mom
back she got done lipo face tits and I
never woke up never woke up you gotta be
looking in the casket though yep
what would you do what would you have
done only your ears and I wouldn't touch
my ears now I'll have this guy they
Scott they take whatever fat you have
you have a very full mouth gulp you you
have a full mouth you absolutely need
some absolutely no women pay a lot of
money for these lips they pay a lot of
money for those lips you got tits and
you got a full mouth yeah it got me too
not like yours but it's you know it's
fun why it's fine you have a fun dick
fun
you were brandon was flapping his dick
oh my god I was reading well here's the
best shower so I want to use his shower
we had music on there and then he was
reading and the doors like this I start
flat he gets only I already filmed it
I've sent it I said
Cillian Rogan I sent it the worst is
rolling in common ramen doesn't even
comment I never I send Rogan pictures of
my dick and he just never says anything
okay it's like come on dude just that
maybe maybe show me your piece just give
it at least give a thumbs up so I don't
feel like complete [ __ ] moral yeah
exactly
I mean nothing but I called it happy
dick Malik had a big problem with his
eyebrow I'm [ __ ] trying to take a nap
you said tomalak great I go I go I go
like this I just sent him that video and
I go cool yeah Malik goes [ __ ] you
Brennan he kept saying like what's wrong
with you is that dick video Mike what
dick videos I didn't know he filmed it
he did I was flapping it it's important
it's flapping the way it was good that
was a good piece it was like nice and
nice and flappy yeah it's cool well done
thanks man gotta do the helicopter
sometimes to hook up Joe it's amazing
how immature we are huh and I have no
excuse I'm so much older than everybody
else you're older and I'm it might be
the worst in some ways hilarious yeah
but who cares
no it's still fun and I'm still getting
away with it so we got to figure out how
to do it again well I really wanted to
see I got I'm doing Crona times July I
what 17 anything I'm doing Addison talus
maybe we can do it then what are you
doing Spokane what are you in doubt same
weekend I'm in Salt Lake 16th to the
18th [ __ ] yeah damn but then what
else do you have coming up nothing
Dallas's last one for a while why I
don't know I'm doing Denver am i doing
Denver in August
no well point to this we could crush
Denver you talking about daddy throw him
down now imagine yeah I can I'll
probably go maybe we should do dad love
to see my friends and family
maybe we should ever well we get a huge
house get it Airbnb like a serious one
or stay with clop and ruin his house let
me and Brandon all of our black we bring
the whole house just bring the whole
gang [ __ ] home and Stevie's gonna
keep your kids up all night playing the
guitar
yeah you don't have many dates daddy
Oh Miami it'd be fun Oh Miami Miami is
my favorite Miami is my favorite
Miami's weather makes me feel lucky
gomez open up for you have my new
[ __ ] eyes Oh do anything how the [ __ ]
I'm gonna look Johnny [ __ ] did he did
did that nut he probably specialize in
teeth I don't know I'm trying to be
funny at all did he say anything about
your hair though did he say well addy
say when you're under you know you could
feel full right his partner is the best
hair transplant guy in the busy of no
desire I would but I mean if you didn't
want that on time and also it doesn't
matter it's not gonna make a difference
let's be honest though you were though
the problem is you started doing this
you become the old guy who's getting
work done or or you the old guy was
great here I don't believe that on my
hair so I don't believe what out that no
we're gonna get shave that we're gonna
we're gonna scalp yet we put some new
product know that when I can when they
can clone hair daddy will have your hair
believe me I will walk in with a full
head of hair and new eyes I'll be great
but until then I'm not doing it
oh you know who came to our show you're
gonna lie you're gonna die you weren't
there
Hootie and the Blowfish he's not sure
yet what a great guy he's a that's
awesome I don't know what songs he sang
III go such a good guy but I didn't know
he was I don't know he was so big he
goes does he have money uh your brother
said your brother said he's so rich he's
one of my favorite go whoo
what do you mean because I thought I
went like this on him over there brother
yeah I he's such a nice guy but I didn't
realize how and then I turn don't think
about it do you know you don't know his
gym no we playing well yet demonetised
but he's a big deal I guess I mean he's
got a Grammy Award when he's still
crunching Wow and I said a joke and it
didn't go well and you didn't hear it I
went hey dearest she says the moment the
Dolphins make me cry too
and I stood there like this yeah and you
know cool man I went
it's from your song yes I know I'm gonna
leave now that was the last time I
thought yeah he can't he watched us he
loved it he loved our show oh yeah yep
really cool really cool guy
very well here's some [ __ ] hits well
I guess he's still only one away we do
as the Dolphins make me can write and
then he went later Blowfish and start
doing country what a story is let me see
his eyes for a second let her cries eyes
you might have been Mikey he might have
gotten the Bryan Callen special well
you're gonna get the Hootie special
because he did before you you're right
and yours are still to be determined
Bubba um he looks good hell of a golfer
to make all right now I don't think my
dog might have gotten Brian Brian I
don't think so hmm good nose on him hmm
hmm he's a handsome fella and a very
talented man please call five days a
week
oh wait go back to Hootie do they still
play sometimes who the Blowfish I think
that just rubber right there used to
always play with a shirt off and I had a
huge problem
let me stop now cuz they're both like
you've got to stop yeah how old did he
say when he's younger than I was I guess
we're comparing he saves 50 was 50 I
think yeah I don't know he's so talented
he was on this season American I don't
want to talk to him about it
otherwise get an opportunity to why
there's a lot of people in the room my
Dolphins joke bombs hmm yes so many is
God how I'm a writer
do you wish you were there now Jay it
would been pretty dope to me just get
talk music yeah Oh Stevie post a picture
with a lynx God get your cotton balls
out of my face bro
um no no it's anyone maybe just took it
posted later he be ship hell posted it
one of the guys bar Malik might have
posted - that's good Fischer at me and
me and oh girl oh we key with your eyes
closed though yeah a picture makes no
sense you know
okay Grillo look at how rugged karela
looks just a tough dude yes he's just a
tough father looks like he's been up for
seven nights in a row but whatever he's
just he he he doesn't sleep he sleeps
five hours a night it's the only person
I've ever seen him live well there's a
lot of guy hours four hours of sleep
he's incredible I've never seen him like
it he doesn't need sleep there's a few
guys like that but I just I marry my age
Pollux
I said Frank's going on editions I'm
amazing this you're not frank grillo
Brian you don't look like Frank Lola who
is if no one's supposed to know maybe
Chappell Chappell did that cuz Chappelle
loves them and I say maybe hope nobody
posted it it's for something a [ __ ]
maybe in their stories
I saw it someone missing maybe and I say
maybe oops wrong way I don't know who
the [ __ ] dude who else was that got a
picture with him was it Justin maybe cuz
it's jealousy Justin in these I don't
know
oh no oh maybe J did did J sub yeah J
did our boy yeah truck Conrad can take
some pictures truck Conrad can do his
whoa
where it is there he is I only want to
be with you look at Malik legs you're
dumb I said looks like you say you got
it from a wheel that's a Stevie sir
Stevie was in a wheelchair this looks
like booty in the blobfish make-a-wish
situation and they use like no
wheelchair for the foot view is in a
wheelchair for from the age of 12 to 13
he got [ __ ] up by a car so he that's
what he was the one who said that he
goes you got Stevie's had a rough go man
he's had
Rothko his parents [ __ ] yeah why he
was in prison
yeah he's yet cancer yep his girlfriend
a porn star
that's pretty good now he's got a
shoehorn lucky shoehorn up his ass no
he's doing well yeah yep I'm gonna start
taking him and Malik out
Maalik out on the road well I have bad
news what they're coming with me you
can't steer sir you can't be your thief
and that's weird cuz we all gotta be
together huh I know it's true got that
whiskey it was nice yep
I feel like we have to figure out the
weight they've replaced it
reading every show every show so lot of
guys how about I get all drunk Friday in
the manager Rachel Rachel right oh the
bottles into it hey see what's wrong
with issues while you empty she's all
what if they're all like did you just
say it - Rachel you son of a [ __ ] you
tapped the bottle ago this needs to be
full tomorrow I was like she was I was
joking though you're so good though huh
that's very good angels and me and the
fried rice at that place very good god
it was a it was it was like wild rice oh
how about your boy Kevin Kevin Beck
Kevin Bayless shout out to Kevin Bandai
we did a workout yeah that dude I love
working out with Kevin because he never
hurts you like he just does he knows
exactly how to warm you up and get you
in a workout situation we were at that
gym what was that CrossFit gym we went
to that was good
and they were like all those like
competitive weight lifters were there
those CrossFit girls were insane oh yeah
that wasn't hot we did a lot of [ __ ]
yeah anyone got a personal best I guess
she broke some record of her purse yeah
I mean not like very good and she do
that but very very cute is it yeah I
probably Club hybrid Fit Club yeah yeah
he knows he trains a lot with the
baseball players but he knows his [ __ ]
he knows his [ __ ] you know it's fun man
he brought don't like witty the best guy
every kid on Sunday more him for
relieving us I brought you doughnuts and
coffee like
he's my DS I'm not gonna suck you off
man he's the best day Kevin's just
[ __ ] I always hang out with Kevin when
I go to super nice guy huh yeah oh yeah
there's a gray area some stud - I gotta
look the kid yeah
nice 230 pounds dress well he's a grand
old time when it ran ran old on time the
grand ole time you live in Phoenix yes I
could Brendan you know what
Scottsdale say this right now I've been
here for 25 years in Los Angeles
if you said Brian pack a bag you got to
go to a lake in Austin Texas or you got
to go to Arizona
I wouldn't [ __ ] I look back I I would
not how did it I wouldn't miss this
[ __ ] place hey tough guy I wouldn't
miss this Falk in place and I said those
exact things on Saturday I said pack
your bags you're the only reason I'm
still in LA I know I knew it while you
figured this out the kids all right but
you just said if I said that you would
go you're the only reason I'm still in
LA let's let rogue and be the canary in
the coalmine let's let him kind of
figure out figure Texas out or wherever
it is he's gonna go and then we'll you
know I always said Joe you go do all the
work and we'll come over and then he
could buy us houses not if he wants us
close to him he should buy us houses
no papa I get my own money you might
need that how about get your little
guest house I'm doing pool boy not the
rules walking around let's do it as soon
as you say you can go to Texas I'll buy
a house you're the only reason I'm still
know I think about I'm the only reason I
had to talk with show time to air you
know Malka was they can shoot below the
belt everything the whole squad would be
down to go feels it was like I'm not
made to LA what if there's a massive
exodus a comedic exodus that goes to
Austin I'm just sick of the [ __ ] around
here why the traffic and the [ __ ] the
homeless percent to some homeless
student my coffee shop you ever see you
ever seen human [ __ ] you ever see Nancy
Pelosi's [ __ ] district in insane
Francisco yeah take a look at it it's
just homeless as far as the eye can see
how's that gone she's a [ __ ] they're
all just like I don't know man
gavin newsom how'd you do in San
Francisco right now again and Pelosi
would beat up Garcetti though said he's
a giant why I don't know look I don't
know what it's like to run a massive
economy like this but I think they're
not doing now I'm talking about so funny
how it's so funny how if you think
government's the answer take a look at
the [ __ ] homeless crisis
it's hilarious it's just [ __ ] it's
yeah but remember you're like - dude if
you tell me all right well I'm telling
you as soon as you say hey the way
everybody's down we'll start the
shopping yeah I'm going yeah when I'm in
San Antonio don't be surprised if during
the week during the day give me at Hotel
Emma and I'm telling you to call me as
soon as you're walking - oh let's move
here I understand but I'm gonna drive
the 45 minutes one hour to Austin and
I'm going to go and look at Ron's
interview I'm in San Antonio June 25 26
27 yes is that the same time unspoken
that's nice day Friday Saturday yeah
well Spokane is up in the air only for
25 26
so I'm gonna drive down to Austin I'll
say it again please
25 26 27 I need a broker only a good
broker they were supposed to let me know
spoken there was a little bit of a scare
who's got a good broker in Austin
oh I'll talk to Robin bet he has
somebody me undies are without a doubt
the best underwear on the planet the
picture I posted in Phoenix with yes
with your three-piece set in my face
yeah but the only thing that's miss is a
nice pair of me under your windows old
ass the IP I put those on because I was
gonna go I go I'm gonna put those on do
you wanna get away right I got me - get
get wet with the chlorine I don't wanna
mess with my me undies
they are the best underwear in the world
committed to standing up against hate
and intolerance creating a world of
science fear of all people so they give
back mm-hmm dude my undies has this
brilliant thing called me undies
membership where every month you get the
softest undies ever right at your door
to show me your door like magic
dude oh and you also get site-wide
savings early access free shipping it's
pure joy they talk about micro mode on
its ear Odysseus Moscow sustainable
fabric fabric encases your three-piece
set and your other reads nug them up man
hug do ya know you ever he ever put your
nuts on a cloud or your other or your
privates on a cloud knock them daddy the
undies offers a range of sizes from
extra small for Brian to for 2x for me
that's right the undies has a great
offer for you guys for first-time
purchase you get 50% free shipping 15
pooja Lee give this supersoft try for
your nuts
it truly is give them different fit tips
off free shipping Brian have your first
order free shipping a 100% satisfaction
guarantee me on ease out calm / fighter
that's me on nice calm / fighter Oh
daddy talk to me about whoop oh my god I
thought you'd never ask dude since
you're into fitness
you're an optimizing your training dude
do you like do you like fitness yeah but
tell me what would you provide these
nuts in your mouth
pray listen everybody yeah take the
guesswork out of your workout listen I
saw rice stationary bike I'm like oh it
says I'm burning 1,500 calories weird
I'm gaining weight oh I don't know what
I'm doing so my fat ass got a real bike
I'm like I know I'm burning calories how
many and I'm guessing and you know I'm
trying to micromanage everything I'm
figuring things out but I don't know so
then I reached out to whoop if it hey
you guys are the best in the business
all you do is wear this little bracelet
because you wanted your back on recovery
strain and sleep do and sleep they test
that you know how they give their
numbers by taking your heart rate every
freaking second a hundred times per
second it tells your output tells your
recovery your strain they got it all man
it's a performance tool to your workout
take the guessing out don't do it
anymore you can get $30 off sending it
yeah dude
$30 off loop they have their 3.0
strapped right now has five-day battery
life and proof strap live heart rate
monitoring in addition a handful of new
app features all you do is download app
connect it to your little loop band and
hit the trails bros sleep
$30 off that swoop comm promo code is
thick that's thick with three C's th
ICCC at checkout safe $30 optimized the
way you train I'm talking performance
tool measures recovery scroll down
please chin your strain your sleep
do you know get a sleep you got I don't
course you don't
I'm doing treat by this you have no idea
strain coaches all right they got it all
man that's woop calm promo code is back
three C's Phalke a staunch in my girls
brought my baby by whose yeah Versailles
the average for Tony boo selling babies
he's enormous
he's an enormous baby but I [ __ ] it
yesterday when a stone shin this
yesterday when I was on packing Tiger
likes to watch music videos I just play
them on YouTube just like random like
fun videos then the weekends new videos
on there have you seen it no it's so
dark in like scary and his head gets cut
off
I see tiger like this that's a big
problem well wife because at the stay in
his rooms from 2 a.m. to 6 a.m. yeah
obviously yeah I just sleep in his bed
oh that's a big problem
he loves the weekend weekends a bad guy
in like now I was pretending Papa ah you
don't want to see somebody's head come
off yeah I don't that's a big problem
yeah Papa [ __ ] up hopefully being at
school today it's like he forgets about
it well hopefully doesn't cut
everybody's head I'm playing the music
video I know
alright what else we'll get alright this
is the first one okay so the show cops
has been on since 1989 it had 25 seasons
while it was on Spike and then I think
it got oh no while it was on Fox moved
to spike and now the week that the
George Floyd protests happens they pulls
cops and cancel it indefinitely I don't
get how that helps the narrative cuz the
cops
those guys are being filmed and there
weren't bad guys then are they also
cancer in first 48 I don't know
America darkness did that problem that
we're living in is you have corporations
that are all of a sudden all-pro black
lives matter because
it affects their bottom line and you
have Twitter that goes crazy and you
have just extremists who are running the
narrative and so anything now that has
to do with cops and seeing them in a
positive light seems to be a what is
that a threat or is that is that
suggesting that you're racist like what
are you talking about so if they shut
down first 40 I'm gonna freak Amish I
found out I saw a great [ __ ] show on
a weekly basis don't bring hops back
I'll bring it back nobody here's 48 to
me but I'm saying people love to watch
it they'll bring it back
they might it's been running dude it's
just it's this this right now
everything's on fire you can't sustain
you can't sustain insanity it'll come
back Oh
get the latest news information about
first 48 find out first 40 is canceled
or renewed they said live PD is
cancelled I mean I guess that shows do
people like watch stuff I think I'll
stop if there's nothing I'll watch it
but throws the same [ __ ] yeah
first 48 always in Oklahoma in New
Orleans it's good show yeah it's a great
show yeah so a couple of days ago
Vanessa Bryant went on to Instagram and
post it on her IG story saying that she
had to block a lot of fan accounts after
the death of Kobe and Gianna because the
algorithm had it that since so many fans
yet all she would see were photos of
them and her as well as her daughter's
couldn't handle it so they went out of
their way to have to block fan accounts
and a lot of fan accounts asked why they
got blocked she just wanted to address
that it was too hard for them to see
Instagram if in the algorithm that you
just see pictures of her dead the
husband and daughter I don't know I
can't imagine what she's going through I
really can't yeah well she has other
kids but yeah if that was me I'd be hard
for me to a disaster it's a disaster
it's terrible I cannot imagine I'm sure
they understand why she blocked it yeah
of course Lee hopefully dude Chappell
showed me some of the dams he gets dude
racist oh my god really
yeah sit like it when he opens up my
show he's like look at what some people
send me dude
I was like you should screenshot that
and post so people know what you deal
with Wow it was awful
oh my god I didn't know he got hate
teams like that I mean not all the time
but but you know their racist love like
nobody's looking
that white old me should screenshot and
post so people know what they're dealing
and get that account out yeah it's a
weird thing and there are there I know
you were telling me then there are
stories about people come out of the
woodwork in all kinds of things for
example there was a young lady who is a
comic very heavy and she said just watch
watch my DMS and you'll see how many men
who are at the show are secret oh yeah
oh yeah I'll be thick Tiki chasers they
think oh there's that famous trend
transgender girl she's like oh your
favorite celebrities in my DM
she's like just banging has a huge [ __ ]
is that true and she's like oh you're
those hardcore rappers and [ __ ] through
my deal ah I love it yeah so well it all
comes out in on your dams the racists
the perverts that whatever or they're
not racist you know and they're just
like it's just such a cheap shot than
that crispy pieces of [ __ ]
this it was so bad like I'm like god man
man there's three end bombs in there was
a monkey reference with a monocot what
was bad like dude you should screenshot
this and post it [ __ ] he didn't know how
to deal with the kids and Eli oh this is
how you do so report it do this but it
but do their private accounts right so
you can't see the [ __ ] are and
that's always ya know these these
dummies don't have the common decency to
have their pictures on this you're too
scared
yeah too scared yeah little cowardly
[ __ ] alright well speaking of human
[ __ ] the actor from the show arrow his
name is Stephen Amell and he's had a
dispute with his neighbor for about
three years because they've had ongoing
illegal construction going on and he
finally had enough he went over and
tried to talk to them about it as well
his wife they got into argument with
their neighbors and then he posts onto
his Twitter a photo of [ __ ] on the roof
and he says that his neighbors came over
and shat on his roof okay well our
next-door neighbor has been a Lully
doing construction or three years I've
not in the past eight that the same
problem the neighbor was doing a legal
[ __ ] and they get the city permit but he
was a big power attorney dude
he would shut the road down to get these
big trees he wanted so no one could get
in and out of our coldest act and my
neighbor is like an 80 year old that to
get picked up from a nursing home so
they would like wheel him around like
the cop the construction and we're like
what do you doing do no one could touch
this guy super powerful dude and was
doing construction around the clock it's
so [ __ ] up Jesus I'm surprised the
city even counting spider mites calm
down well they'd these fine you and I
work for the city yep or they find you
and you just go cool I'll pay the fine
and you just do what any of this goes
well that's the other thing you can do
this goes wicked baller oh sure it was
like you you want to do what but I think
that's hilarious that somebody took a
[ __ ] on his roof because for me I
wouldn't I'd be like all right I
wouldn't acknowledge it you take a [ __ ]
on my baller movies [ __ ] on the doorknob
yeah dries up in the Sun it's [ __ ]
awesome I can't smell it know that I'm
like also where's the toilet paper I
just took a [ __ ] got upset with her
after we do think we could but being
neighborly
Cass called out multiple times don't say
Casto say my wife does not that backyard
they say she snuck on into our backyard
[ __ ] on her roof he is he sure that she
did that that's a pretty badass move
it's more of a claim we don't know if he
has like footage of this that he's just
not showing but he's pretty adamant that
she came and shot on his roof I guess
he's very certain about it huh
are we gonna just ask about how staff
was she hot though we don't know we
don't know what the neighbors look like
how the [ __ ] yeah its own roof yeah
that's gonna be tough
yeah especially without them noticing
lot so you know ain't you'd have to be
to climb somebody's ripping [ __ ] on it
there are people Thank You Lonnie the
jokes kind on you like you did all that
work there's there are people that pay
women good money to come over and take a
[ __ ] oh yeah in their toy later in the
totally yeah and then just leave it yes
that's a fetish by the way ladies and
gentlemen you all are people it's about
a buck Bryan put some stuff in his ear
this weekend and get that earwax oh [ __ ]
I was getting one black black stones
came out of there these Jiang shop was
like yo-yos you know car look at this
come over he was making him a to go get
it out he goes you guys see the brush
start throwing up I was like what's
wrong it was now I could hear why did
you have that in your hair
can I get ear wax in my ear and then you
put the solution a you just use water
plunger and it's like this yellow wax
guys and those rose door dude black
that's good I was getting vertical made
me get I get wax buildup but everybody
has it but sometimes you have to clean
it out if you're me some people just
have it like like you know it's just
[ __ ] I get mine doing it you should
look refreshing oh it does you feel like
ah you can hear all of us have it is
just some people some people get it so
it pushes on their inner ear so if I
remember this hot girl in elementary
school would she had these cones yeah
those are [ __ ] sucks it out that's
what they say but it's not true you
didn't do it now it's it's a [ __ ]
thing this girl brought for
show-and-tell and I was disgusted it's
so so watch your candles where they work
and they sell them still what comes out
of your did that all this voice agent
what's it called Romeo Romeo
placed on a hollow carrier made from a
yep that's Priya's finish a brown wax
ovens bleed by ear care and practice
would be a mix of Iraq's to breathe and
bacterias nothing else about so my
professors when I want to audio
engineering school audio engineering
school they said they did it in a chain
the way they hear helymus shots you see
this ear candling practitioners yeah
Reiki healers ear practicing can
practice people who work with crystals
they're all far off frauds
they're all phonies all of them there's
zero there's there's zero effectiveness
to it besides the placebo effect they're
all frauds they're all actors where it
didn't work out and now they're healers
get the [ __ ] out of here if you're a
healer
you're a liar how's that sound well no
Brian but there's some exceptions no
there aren't no there aren't if you
practice astrology tarot cards [ __ ]
healing with your hands but you don't
touch them all that stuff you liar
you liar okay but if it says it just
removes your wax and that huh that's the
only claim if it doesn't so but I said
all right I look so refreshed I dunno I
ever doing tonight that I was like man
all my all this wax but they're there
they have beeswax and I burnt it without
it being in my ear and guess what the
same amount of wax came out you know
they draw toxins from your feet have you
ever seen that well they put your feet
in a solution and all the brown comes
out that's a lie - that's a lie you're
all liars you're all eyes and if you pay
for that stuff you're dumb as [ __ ] I
knew an actor who went to a healer and
the guy told him to go to an
intersection and break a [ __ ] egg on
his stomach cuz he do it he did Bradley
Cooper
and look guys a [ __ ] dummy - you're a
dumb-dumb well I need you out then you
bring their side that ear solution huh
let me bring that you're so well it's
great what's it called it's just you can
get in pharmacy it's just a twitch it's
a it looses the wax and then you take a
plunger and you take water and you
plunge it out of your ear that's great
that's it dip rocks right there's a bus
uh-huh okay rocks it's awesome oh maybe
I'll start the thin boy debug rocks boat
with you really okay so this video of a
protester twerking in front of police
officer he made it on two barstool dude
is a caret-- porn star shout to her but
she posted a video
of during a protest this guy getting
sucked off I see that the guys on the
sign like well you know black lives
matter he's getting sucked oh I'm kind
of see buddy cool she posted on like
Twitter yeah okay let that stuff go I
guess yeah we'll get Deamonte all right
let me see what the me see the Torian
get D monetize if we do it all right
let's not watch it well sure to Brian
just for kicks and edit it oh no she's
not naked those are pants well that's a
professional stripper office it is
sloppy it's a real stripper oh she's a
lady now she's a lady
great ass
the cops roll cops are all like cool man
yeah we're just sitting here patrolling
so that was fantastic yeah just try to
keep everybody safe my in-your-face
coupling my keys generally I'll just
just any others just being mad at all
the cops any others that's helpful you
know what would happen
you know it's decided look like without
cops good luck good [ __ ] luck drives
me nuts that's right oh I love us Oh
free nudes Lhasa mmm-hmm yeah keep going
chill yeah Brian get your pizza Oh keep
going good start
nah keep going okay keep Alek
you can't miss it I was watching it
while I was on the plane I know the guy
next to me saw me looking at it this is
a May 27th now I'm weird what does she
have to take you down that means
yesterday when I was on the on the plane
go back up maybe it's not there anymore
no no do they put the porn stuff on a
different no she's still making porn oh
yeah she's a kid though I think right I
think so I think she has such about it
man where's it at it was on there
oh well not anymore who's that what's
that kicked off it with this deep
monetize their [ __ ] no no we're okay
next time just give me a next time is
that we're second instagram.com
did you guys watch Dave Chappelle's
special that came out 8:46 special
caught more of like miniature special I
suspect he's not doing jokes but it's
very powerful it's fantastic so I was
free on YouTube Rios was from Netflix
though and he mentioned something about
Don Lemon yes okay I say so he talks
about Don Lemon and then coz Donnellan
was calling everybody out saying how
you're quiet now you're quiet now and
Chappelle goes off on them because I
didn't need to do anything because the
streets are doing the talking for me
you sometimes you don't need to say
anything correct correct
I guess now silences means you're a
racist too so you can't win the CEOs
answer me do you want to see a celebrity
right now say what they want like their
opinion on it yes the crowd wants no yes
do we give a [ __ ] like ja Rule thinks
that's a bit from them does matter about
celebrity lemon respond I think that
young people who are out here in the
streets don't really care what we have
to say especially called 846 that's time
how long that cop was on the guys neck
846 you start about this issue I think
it's great he's doing this platform talk
about this weekend oh yeah so Don Lemon
agreed
don't let me suck you off now I think
yeah I'm married to a man so I'm
hopefully he doesn't cheat on his
husband understand if you were so I
doubt he would suck did you eat your
lids done you get around Donny time to
Hanscom p.m. Donny yeah yeah it's part
of the media though that scares me yeah
done done but you can't suck doesn't
impress me with his is reporting any
more than Tucker Carlson does Jay Ferrel
ha I heard about this why is this he
shared a story about being had on I
thought this was recent it was pretty
recent he said earlier this year I think
so this is a story about him getting a
beam misidentified as another black
person
cops kneeling on his neck as well and
there's actual security footage when
he's talking about it it's all places
some of it here been in Ventura I see an
officer to the left of me
I'm not thinking anything of it because
I'm a law-abiding citizen and also keep
in mind I got my Bose headphones on no
noise Katz noise cancelling headphones
it's really I mean I'm in my zone right
now I look to my left the officer I see
him coming with guns blazing I see him I
see him say get on the ground put your
hands up like you're an airplane as he's
looking at me I'm thinking that he's
making a mistake so I'm looking past
where he's looking I'm looking at this
and I'm looking past me this is about to
be terrible no he was coming to get me
full officers got their guns blazing
they telling me to get on the ground
spread my arms out they put me in cuffs
the officer took his knee put it on my
neck on it wasn't as long as a George
Floyd but I know how that feels
I said why are you doing this like
what's wrong I said you fit the
description of a black man in this in
this area with gray sweatpants on and a
grey shirt I told them I said if you
look goggle right now Jay Pharoah you
will see that you made a big mistake
a minute later after I was detained in
cuffs and keep in mind they've already
asked me do you wanna you you want to
sit on the side I'm like no I don't even
want to be on the ground they come back
they say we're sorry we just got a call
in that it's not you I say you'll get
these get these excuse my french get
these handcuffs off of me I had never
been in cuffs below up and said that
point I'm a law-abiding citizen and I'm
from the burbs you know luckily my
parents what they did was they tried to
shelter me and my sister for years so we
never saw that I haven't I didn't
experience firsthand racism in America
until this year
black lives always matter my life
matters and I'm still here to tell my
story but I could have easily been on a
mod or Barry
or a George Floyd and I'm not and I
could tell my story so I'll tell y'all
this is what you need to do educate
yourselves educate yourselves on the
laws understand what the cops are saying
to you so if they try to flip anything
on you on our young black men our black
men in general we have the knowledge and
we have the power to overthrow that
because we we're well-rounded we know
what's going on be in the know this
smart guy I love Jay Pharoah this smart
guy you know you can't expect not to be
mad about that you know and I think what
super The interestings I've been
watching a lot of debates among black
people black liberals black
conservatives but I've been doing this
on YouTube it's really fascinating
because one of the things that the white
liberal left tries to do is suggest that
all black people think the same they
create this [ __ ] fencing around them
and they they they they treat them like
that why people need to protect them
it's got to be so [ __ ] condescending
and I think what's interesting is that
if you listen to black the average black
person who gets together in a group they
have they're all over the place like
anybody else everybody has a different
point of view on this and one of the
main things you start to hear is this
idea that they have to figure out they
have to help them themselves and get
them to they'll always talk about the
fact that they have work to do within
their own community yeah and that's what
that's what I love so there's a this is
sparked a whole debate among it seems to
me you know it's heightened the debate
among black people
okay you guys remember that imagined
thing that those celebrities did with
Gallacher doshas I talk about all whites
less so embarrassing this need white
suburbs who are like we I take
responsibility for why I'm not forced a
you guys got a long you guys gonna help
you look at all the two hun good good
for but hey dudes you know what now that
you said you take responsibility white
celebrity whoever the [ __ ] you are I bet
I bet all the boys in the hood are just
breathing a sigh of relief guys guys the
Aaron Paul and all these other actors
are taking responsibility thank God
we're safe now
thanks a lot doctor no helps you [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] oh so what about this gin
well obviously God the majority of
people agree with you guys
what anything yeah and so no creature
trace himself Hollywood they've so
embarrassing well no did he recreate one
no no he was just talking about it good
he was terrible lack of diversity in
this video first of it which is a joke
and then I can't wait to go bad on this
in my stand-up this is on right this is
nothing you wrote the thing that bill
just bit tired being lectured dude nice
always think that general public needs
to see my face they can't get the cinema
so I needed to do something I agree
that's when you look in their eyes you
know that even if they're doing
something good they're sort of thing yet
I could weep and I could weave that what
good a person I am oh dear it's so true
you'd totally tell they're literally
like don't forget about me yeah I'm on
it too you're using a lot of this comic
is posting this okay this black life
thing like where where were you a month
ago where were you doing the Kaepernick
stuff where were you where were you an
eighty to a black young black well
actually a two black people from
Toddlers to the age of 74 go were shot
in Chicago in one weekend well if you're
all of a sudden Hollywood now is like
wait is this popular let me jump on here
and get myself on social media your
social media posts don't mean a [ __ ]
thing
they don't make anybody safer they don't
make any black lives better get the [ __ ]
out of here it's so condescending
it's so embarrassing I swear to god it's
what I said before it's like they're
literally like cats chasing a light beam
you go from one movement to the other
and then you lose interest this is my
thing how does that know that this is
lame as [ __ ] how they are you so out of
touch how do they not know that this
isn't cuz they're ours we're all gonna
like Tim the [ __ ] up black white asian
it's whoever you are nobody sees goes
out man powerful they're good PDA hey
thanks a lot
doing it you do us so much thanks for
standing for equality like oh I stand
for inequality thanks for standing for
peace and I stand for war what the [ __ ]
you say there the word is the worst and
they don't my favorite actors I don't
give a [ __ ] about her who was that she
was in the oj oj this guy these [ __ ]
actors would we're trying to act like
they give a [ __ ] it's so embarrassing
and whoever put this on is a [ __ ]
Yoker we don't like it
bunch of yo-yos yeah bunch of duh I
don't give a [ __ ] about any of them
though you're all off my Island out out
but it was that guy that's Justin
Theroux my North Star was that talk
about that guy Oh easy you win a beanie
- hey get out of here all easy all y'all
get out of here
she's in there too which is a bummer
okay Kristen Bell is the voice of frozen
Sally raised in her past
who's that girl the Olympian girl very
cute Aly Raisman yeah yeah she's very
sexy but hey guys I get it guys though
actually take action today great
movement whites for blacks org it's so
it's so cringy I'll tell you what and
even black for like why couldn't go into
the black community and find children
that don't have parents or in the foster
system and and raise them how about that
do everything you can to make their
lives better that's you're not huh no
[ __ ] but that doesn't do anything no
this may not upset oh it just makes me
hate Hollywood more I just got there so
embarrassing dude every Oscars is a new
the Oscars every Oscars a new class it
was transgender it's me - it's what it
thousands whatever the flavor of the
year is let's rip our mast off and get
into a group of a thousand now cuz vagon
anyway what's black about when I worked
Oscars in they're like oh you have to
wear me to pin like I remember that like
no I don't yeah like you have to if
you're on the air I'm like I'm not
wearing it man yeah I don't know enough
detail I'm not into this yeah not that
I'm wants women to be raped I don't know
it's right when it's not that way I'm
not wearing this since I get more
notified of it it's only could it make a
change there if you don't tow the line
you you will get boycott your business
you looking at end up where one but the
point is is I gave up a little fight
yeah I put a little fight you have I
don't think I want one to be honest I
went I went I'll wear out because they
want to it they're like well we were a
rose Mike yeah whatever I'm not wearing
a pin assist meet you want yeah I'm not
part of the problem right
Barisan I think like I always say I
think that the net result at the end of
the day is gonna be the most the ball
for that sets us back that makes me a
shops are going through a hard [ __ ]
time and as we always say on this show
the majority of cops don't walk into the
Phoenix stand-up life this guy goes oh
dude big fan hears like this thing on
his wrist and it looked melty I don't
even know - yes cop no time very tough I
had a Vegas guy I don't know I'm sorry I
can do our show we have a lot of cops
were counting with him and and obviously
and I think everybody knows this
including people in the movement that
the majority of cops are great people do
a great there's some power powered
[ __ ] in every group and they ruin it
for everybody
you have [ __ ] in every group and
they have to be held to account for sure
but those III have to say I have to say
what's your take on it's a touchy
subject but when that when those two
white cops in Atlanta got in the fight
with that black guy and he was resisting
arrest and then he punched I think both
them in the face and took that got away
and took the Taser mom turned shots it's
excessive force you need to kill that
guy yeah the only problem with the prom
is yeah is because those guys don't do
well in high function situation high
stressful situations they go to the the
result which the equalizers the gun like
I shouldn't die but my question is he
should have got [ __ ] up I agreed and I
agree I but as a police officer when if
somebody shoots you with your own taser
your body locks up now you have to know
that your your partner's there the
partner both those guys don't know we're
really that that that taste is gonna hit
it happens in a split second you just
got in a fight with the guy the guy
punched you the guy strong he gets away
he takes your taser he shoots at you
what I'm trying to say is that if you in
your training if your body lock somebody
comes back and takes your gun you can
die so so so explain to me how you as a
human being a military Sentara there was
another cop there though right but they
might have been terrified I'm just
saying I I'm just saying I
in a situation it's a pan to pan it's a
panic move it's a panic move it sucks
but that actually a four in the police
training and manual is considered a
legitimate use of lethal force it just
is for the precise reason that in that
situation if your body locks up you
can't defend yourself neither one of
those cups may have known where the
Taser was gonna hit so you panic you
pull your gun you shoot I think I think
you can also say that if you are a
citizen and you punch the cop in the
face fight him and take his taser and
try to shoot him with it that's not very
safe for you a cop is the bad cop is
gonna is gonna try to save himself and
maybe shoot about it right so I'm sorry
but some of the some of the
responsibility must rest on the guy
resisting arrest that way I mean that's
that's pretty that's a resisting that's
pretty crazy
when you're when you're that strong
fighting off two dudes punch them in the
face and you turn a point a Taser at
them
I can understand it I understand I agree
I agree I agree he didn't lose sight you
know I agreed and certainly life you're
like it's excessive I agree with those
cops will come to their family well
that's what I'm saying I think I think
it was a panic move I I think I might go
I don't know if he should I never got in
that situation cuz he shoot one guy with
a taser taser is not deadly I'm the
other cop why don't you tackle the [ __ ]
up and take them dude why would you go
from a distance I don't know why
III don't know cuz I never been in that
situation right I don't it happened so
fast who knows I don't know it's weird
again I'd shoot a Taser yeah look man
maybe maybe we'll find out maybe when
the guy turns with a Taser
how do you know if you don't know he's
had he has a gun nobody knows fighting
oh no no they know it's taser because he
took his taser I understand yeah and
they're also yellow your Stan taser yeah
they're not black yeah
they're a different color a purpose it's
it's it's a it's a tough one
well they both what I both lost their
jobs did they both yeah I thought one
one did and the chief please step down
is the chief of the police in Atlanta
african-american are white
yeah even the attorney for books right
now in this heat in this a woman yeah
it's a woman you want to deal with it
well I'm out in right now and this is
infinitely charged situation that it's
the worst thing you can do right so
everybody is yeah everybody's on it you
know the top two shooting a black men
should be on the last the last last
resort my again again sometimes if you
haven't been in that situation you think
your life is in danger
we'll have to probably more qualified
tops in it or that was just one of those
times when again in in in technically
that is a allowed and you would not be
just trouble well then if you do the
bill if you can go back and change the
policing that's fine but can I ask you
something if you don't how what does
that law look like so a guy a guy turns
hits takes your taser and shoot you with
it your body locks up then it takes your
gun and shoot you to me as the policy
would have to be that's he's that you
can't let that stand
can't kill him though well if you don't
have a taser you what do you do do you
let him shoot you and lock up and then
maybe take your gun but there's another
guy there be I let's say you you me and
chin but you're not thinking that way in
that moment when it happens right I get
you and I don't know I I don't say that
because I've never been there I might
know if you and chin are fighting right
and you in and you get Chin's taser
I'm liking why would you think that look
why would you fight why would you punch
the cop in the face and take his taser
and try to shoot him with it you
shouldn't do that you don't say any
price should he got a beatin I mean not
a skilled I agree he doesn't deserve to
lose his life I agree that he doesn't
deserve to lose his life for that like I
if I could turn the yes well she shot
him in the leg or something or I'm just
saying that I think in that moment where
you go that guy's gonna [ __ ] tase me
I'm gonna lock up but about here's the
prom be to play devil's advocate it
happens to up well we're cops like oh we
just panic this guy tons
in 2019 no no hold on hold on hold on
nope you're wrong on our big difference
oh but if you're armed and you're in a
shootout with the cops yeah you should
shoot yeah yeah
so unarmed nine unarmed is of course to
many but but a big difference between a
hundred how many more over the history
of this situation so there has been with
the with the deaths of these these men
and the rallies and the protests in the
past I'm gonna help you argue in here
police heavies those on unarmed
situations have you ever looked into
those unarmed situation and I have
circuits very dicey whereas good ties
were two of them they tried I think to
got Polly found convicted but the other
ones it even went to court and those
guys were kind of justified though it
was dicey situation where the guy was
charging a lot more cha riding or I had
a police officer I had a police officer
down were armed so the cop shoots so so
a police officer from Utah who is a
giant Samoan man was explaining he said
listen dude he is he's a he's Samoan and
he works with he works with black and
and Mexican and Guatemalan people of the
people who are not white and they're
police officers they're SWAT guys and he
said to me he said dude just keep in
mind that just because somebody's
unarmed and you're a police officer and
they come out here he goes he was I'm
300 pounds if I came at you and you're a
cop I can kill you you're a small guy it
doesn't mean I can't kill you or do some
serious damage to or take your gun from
you so you have to all look like you
said to your point just because
someone's unarmed and they come at you
these are the this is this is now when
we doesn't mean not doesn't mean
harmless yeah it means that you could be
very dangerous so now that you have to
say unarmed well I'm with you with that
one if they come out guys you know the
temperature rights aside right now to
the credit of protesters and to the
credit of the black community who
protested they have they've gotten taken
to the streets and I think a lot of
police departments have listened which
is why it went from a hundred to two to
nine in 2019 a lot of progress still
work to do of course but a lot of
progress we have to lay just it has to
be we have to take some perspective here
it's not all doom and gloom is what I'm
saying mm-hmm and when you give all the
cop
the finger like these protesters no you
can't it's just it's just not helping I
know it's just not it's just [ __ ] not
don't you
let's change the subject here check this
out
I'll just play it for you you can dodge
a brick you can dodge a ball that's a
great movie yeah I just saw this on Gold
Center holy it looks like it's throwing
bricks but some people are saying their
star from but it makes that noise that
[ __ ] sound they were not the real
brick somebody dodge them all good job
on matters yeah first thought is just
bad parent the last one are you guys
into gilfs at all sure all right what do
you think of her 60 to 62 years old and
apparently a lot of younger guys are
hitting up on her Instagram Oh God you
mean guys that grew up with mommy issues
[Music]
man I like a female bryan callen when
she was young roll up I think she was
busted when she was young they got hot
she's really changing the night hats not
a good feel for a butterfly works out
all the time yes she was busted for a
long time oh there you go I'm impressed
yeah that's just good-looking older lady
I said I might sit by my sari how old
she 62 Oh should take a run at those
wrinkly bags I don't like the way you
described her would you split a graham
cracker with her old ass ah well I just
saw it on the picture well young lady no
I I probably wouldn't but um I'm very
impressed
take the grab off so Belle hey I'm
impressed that she's taking such good
care of herself she's a good-looking
woman yeah a lot of young dudes after
all right now oh yeah a lot of men like
that a lot of well you know a lot of
young dish she's getting a lot what 100%
water yes good for her is right dick
down
bless I love people that fight gravity
like to her and bryan callen surgeon
tomorrow yeah okay you're fighting it
I'm having surgery on my face how
superficial are you I'm a fight well
dude I can't see how did I get talked
into this first of all my mom started
with my mom I don't know dude I don't
know it started with my mother
we should call my mom to see I guarantee
she warns me about my tear ducts and all
that she just she can find death in
anything do you think this place had
some work soon so she just works out no
she had work out scared yeah it's I
don't know I think there really no you
don't think there no papa
look gonna go now they're shutting cut
that tight listeners you take care of
yourselves scrolling no those are fake
Bubba come on could be some of them old
saggy implants though you know maybe I
don't know I don't like you that you're
such an ageist you 37 that well she
looks [ __ ] crazy there what yeah
that's a tough picture no you're not
37 yeah you're at least 37 zone you know
what my pet peeve is oh yeah I am no
it's when people forget their age yeah
when they know their age nice we got it
I get lost nope I might be 38
mm-hm I might be 36 if you don't that's
35 that's fine too I was born in 83
ma'am what are you doing calculating
nothing just hanging out
talk amongst yourselves you call your
mom right now no you called J yeah I am
just find out how old I am that's right
but J doesn't want people know how old
he is either he don't give a [ __ ] I
don't he's two years older me Jay he'll
be at least thirty nine close to 40 well
guys my birthday is March 18 1983 I
don't think we need call my brother
hello yeah how is your brother
shut up what's up how would your brother
yeah I thought you have to be big to
know you should know his age
why yes 3073 yeah hey J we're going to
San Antonio yeah no I texted you back
yeah look for a good cat so I guess
Santa is gonna be fighting the kid again
I can't pay you guys though Hotel I'm
Ariana hey j-bird you're on you're on
the podcast right now what are you doing
right now
oh you do you still have those dogs that
are impossibly hairy yeah what are they
doing it getting hair everywhere they
sleep in this bed asleep in your bed DOS
dude that's over 100 pounds and they're
the Shaggy's other pictures do you have
any pictures of your dogs or does to RAM
I was hoping to see you I was hoping to
see your dog
I showed you mine plenty of time hey J
how about when Brian did his ear wax
little San Antonio is only a week away
well it's actually the 25th so it's ten
days away pull out that big old angry
hog hey hey well how about we tan our
bodies I need to tan my torso to you
you're whiter than I am bro yeah keep it
light hey man that's weird
you got you got your heads brown and
your arms are brown everything else is
white
your body's as white as your dog's face
how old's your dog 27 she's 12
that's an old dog yeah well they're real
cute buddy
grab shoulders tell me get that big dick
out get that big day job I know you're a
little too private for me I don't know
what's going on did you have enough
whiskey this weekend angel in that room
cast those it's too good really but it
doesn't have that
sweet finish like the other one it's
still sweet but maybe not as sweet but
it's good I think the rum cast they got
us those a little bit more expensive
yeah it's fantastic
yeah get my eyes done tomorrow do you
have any advice daddy you'll see in a
little bit okay all right I'm 37 man 37
thanks haven't palomino anymore that's
still very young don't know yeah you
were 40 dude I'm so much older than you
I'm almost 20 years older I bet I wasted
a lot of time and money and money gotta
get going here
yeah a lot do times on your side will be
when I get my ice and I look 40 can't
wait to be feel really different yeah
I'm coming I'm coming in the next day I
can't do anything just venules I can't
wait so apparently I'll have to I may
not be able to see very well I guess I
have to wear some you guys drove around
it's gonna be great oh yeah yeah I got
it's gonna be a tough one I think I just
think a full-bore get your teeth done
little off the tip of the nose get your
face pull back no I don't want you going
to the knife only go under once dude you
want to have to keep going under I don't
have to do any take Tate and if you
learn anything from Kanye's mom it's
don't key to it all huh through it all
yeah do it all at once
all right San Antonio is that it for
current events that was it San Antonio
25th 26th 27th there's a good chance
Brendan Schaub might be joining he's
just sold out what's right nope
you're welcome it's not sold out I
haven't problem I am by monkeys market
hey you're welcome you're annoying me
now
yeah Hotel Emma okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
grant you access to my favorite hotel
right I have the owner's personal we
should do we should do is we should go
through houses in Scent and Elston yeah
oh you're serious I am
we'll talk about it kids we love you we
love you guys think boy birch stick boy
calm for everything yeah probably in San
Antonio spoke in which I suppose we at
next week they're gonna push that
because you guys are dealing with some
[ __ ] out there they are gonna push
that till July thirtieth damn cancelled
no hey hey reschedule oh so we'll do the
bike right then I love you guys
alright spoke in July 30th everybody's
tickets all the sold-out shows is just
getting pushed at the July 30th all
right but I will be in San Antonio with
Bryan Callen Hotel Emma be in Salt Lake
City sold-out Tampa Bay and then we're
adding Irvine end of August as well
alright
t5 kid I come awesome tickets just wanna
sale and that is September 2426 get your
tickets do you back here I come
this thing keys out this old man's out
Bryan good luck on your surgery thanks
buddy
this the fire in the kid we're out